[Musica]
chi c'è marino è così che cosa è quello
il coniglio il coniglio ma non è pasqua
siamo a settembre o non deve essere un
altro episodio di nascondino con i passi
che entrano a casa di anita
ebbene sì nuovo episodio per anno i
cattivi questa volta de il primo
l'abbiamo già visto il coniglio pazzo di
pasco ve lo ricordate e molto cattivo il
problema è che merlino è uscito fuori
devo assolutamente andare a recuperarlo
ma non farmi prendere dal coniglio
mi raccomando lasciato un bel mi piace
entro questa volta quattro secondi 4 3 2
1 tempo scaduto si siete riusciti ora
mettetevi comodi e prendete i pop corn e
e speriamo di vincere questo challenge
nascondino assieme
andiamo a recuperare merlino fuori
ragazzi mi è venuta un'idea geniale per
riuscire a non farmi trovare dal
coniglio o per distrarlo vi ricordate
nella challenge in cui ho sconfitto il
coniglio come lo sconfitto se ve lo
ricordate scrivetelo qua sotto nei
commenti come ha sconfitto unite al
coniglio cattivo nella challenge di
pasqua e se non l'avete vista a voi
andate a vederla dopo questo video
comunque userò la stessa arma e come
arrivo morellino pensavo fosse in
pericolo dal coniglio invece sta
inseguendo le lucertole
ai
oggetto
[Applauso]
aiutato
prendi questa
ciao non merlino lascia la carota
berlino e per il coniglio non è per te
[Musica]
1 lasciala subito lascia
il solito ladro si lascia berlino no
adesso subito la carota è per te per il
coniglio come sempre vermeer e solito
ladro vi ricordate quella volta che
tiravo le banane anche brilla ma perché
le ha rubate e le ho mangiate o no
alcuni gli stessi questo berlino perché
ad akron messo nel mirino lascia dov'è
finita in asta rosati ha vinto questo
vengono alcuni view prendiamo berlino
vieni qua non è per te
dove amministrare
prendi questa
devo approfittare della distrazione
berlino ha rubato la carota coniglio re
il coniglio sta seguendo inseguendo
berlino non possa stare a salvarlo ogni
volta devo ritornare dentro e scappare
così potrò vincere il round
ragazzi siamo riusciti a vincere il
primo round grazie a un berlino che è
distratto il cappellino merli è il
solito ladro
passiamo ora al secondo round evitiamo
chi ci aspetta che ragazzi secondo round
non ho ancora visto chi è il cattivo del
secondo round
però ho deciso di scendere al piano di
sotto
perché ci sono più nascondigli
interessanti in più ho deciso di
prendere questo lenzuolo
vi ricordate in quale il video sia stato
questo nessuno cui ho fatto i buchi per
a vestirmi da fantasma e poi per
spaventare vitale e merlino vediamo chi
si ricorda in quale video è successo
scrivetelo nei commenti comunque userò
questo lenzuolo stile fantasma per
nascondermi meglio non so chi sarà il
cattivo spero che sia un cattivo che ci
caschi
ok andiamo ora al piano di sotto e
scopriamolo assieme ragazzi al piano di
sotto di paura
[Musica]
si no
che strano che non ci sia nessuno qua
bene meglio così
magari il cattivo e al piano di sopra
oppure fuori ne sarai ancora più
difficile per lui trovarmi avete sentito
pt
ciao
sì
per un pelo per poco non mi trovavo alla
dietro alla porta meglio che metto
subito questo ne sono addosso
così magari mi scambia per il muro
magari più sconvenienti zerbi e non mi
troverà pighi ok ragazzi ora pro
mimetizzarmi
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
ok ragazzi siamo al terzo nella
cameretta
forse è meglio che decide un
nascondiglio prima entra il prossimo
cattivo non sa non vedo nessuno
meglio così almeno un po di tempo per
nascondermi la porta è aperta
posteriormente sul letto
ricordate il lupo sono molto profondo
quindi penso che posso parlare
normalmente e forse si sta svegliando
fatto sotto al letto sono nascosta sotto
al letto
spero che non mi trovi quaggiù è ancora
lì che dorme ma quanto tempo davvero
storico e foto
prima o poi si sveglierà e mi
cercheranno
mi sta cercando di paura di un rabbioso
[Musica]
graz il lupo è uscito fuori con
spiegarmi cercare in teak intorno fuori
a chiave ok chiuso a chiave
non dovrebbe riuscire ad aprire la porta
a frassino riesce neanche ad aprire le
maligne perché alle zampe ragazzi
abbiamo vinto il terzo round
quindi ho vinto due partite mio persone
sono in vantaggio e ho vinto la
challenge
iscrivetevi nei commenti secondo voi chi
era il cattivo che faceva più paura di
tutti secondo me penso il lupo voi quale
se diete mi raccomando lasciati un bel
mi piace questo video se non mi seguite
su instagram andati a seguirmi il nome
di the stories se volete seguitemi anche
solo testa e ora vi lascio a 4 caselline
su cui cliccare per vedere i miei altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite e
buona visione
[Musica]